thank you so much tom i appreciate the
introduction
uh so hello everyone i am incredibly
excited to be here this is my first time
uh at stanford so i'm thrilled to share
with you
a few lessons i've learned i'd really
like to just kind of
share my story um i think that it's
maybe
somewhat non-traditional my
style and my personality is very casual
so if you have
questions as i'm going through this
please just
raise your hand i would love to engage
and keep this really discussion oriented
and dynamic so i'll jump in i'm going to
share my story and really focus on
sort of the early days of taskrabbit
actually at the time it was wasn't even
called taskrabbit yet
it's called runmyerrand.com and i'll
share that story with you too
um but it wasn't until we came out
here in 2010 a couple years after i
started
that i raised venture capital funding
and participated in an incubator program
that facebook fund was running
just really took off from there so
this is me at ibm um i was a software
engineer
at ibm for about seven years i worked as
a c-plus plus programmer i worked on
a product called lotus notes and domino
how many of you have heard of notes and
domino all right i love this
so this is a product that literally
millions of people around the globe
used every day on a daily basis it was
an amazing experience
i loved my team i loved who i worked
with
i got to work on really interesting
things
but i always felt like i was i was
missing out on something i felt like
there were other skills i had that i
that i wanted to explore and do on a
daily basis
and it got really amplified one time
a year every year and this was when
we held this massive conference called
lotusphere
and they would invite customers from all
around the globe is about 20
000 people would go down to orlando
florida
and ibm would rent out disney basically
for the week
and it was the one time of year that
they let the engineers talk to actual
customers
it was very exciting for me uh this is
me
and my team at lotusphere and uh this
was set up
in something that they called meet the
developers lab
and so literally customers would come in
i remember this one woman
she worked for a a bank a massive bank
uh she was the i.t person there
um deploying notes and domino and she
was having this problem with
one of her users and email archiving
and i was in charge of this email
archiving
feature in the product so she came in
with her laptop and she was like ah
i have this user's uh actual email file
like on
on a usb disk like can i show it to you
will you debug it right here for me can
we find the bug and fix it and i was
like
yes let's do that that sounds amazing
and so literally in this meet the
developers lab i was like coding
patched her product sent her new version
and she was on her way
now this was at a time where a typical
software life cycle was about 18 months
we like burnt cds packaged them up
mailed them out to customers there was
no agile there was no weekly sprint
planning there was no
deploying every day every night which we
do now at taskrabbit
so it's really exciting for me to
actually meet this customer
in the real world know that she was
having a problem that i could fix
immediately for her
patch her system and sent her on her way
it was awesome and so
i always knew that i wanted to do
something more entrepreneurial at some
point
and the taskrabbit story actually starts
with a dog
not a rabbit uh this is my dog
kobe he uh he lived till he was 13
a hundred pound yellow lab amazing dog
my husband and i were sitting at home
one night
we were getting ready to go out to
dinner and we called a cab to come pick
us up take us across town and we're
living in boston at the time this was
about
february i remember because it was cold
and it was snowing outside
and we realized we were out of dog food
and
kobe was over 100 pounds we kept them
very well fed we're very responsible
doggy parents and my husband kevin
is also in technology in fact as a
quick quick uh tidbit we're high school
sweethearts
and we would spend friday nights
building computers together and so we
were always involved in technology i
know it's really geeky really nerdy
um we would go to computer shows and
like buy motherboards and like put them
together and
um so that's how he wooed me it was very
exciting
uh so kevin also in technology also a
total nerd we'd always have these very
geeky conversations in the house and
that cold winter night it turned into
wouldn't it be nice
if there's just a place online we could
go say we needed dog food name the price
we're willing to pay
we're certain that there was someone in
our own neighborhood that'd be willing
to help us out
why not right there's got to be someone
at the store at this very second
and why can't i connect with them now
this was february of 08
um just a few months earlier the iphone
had come out
all of the sudden people had these
mobile devices on them 24 7.
isn't it funny to think just like five
or six years ago the iphone came out um
and facebook was just breaking out of
the college scene and becoming more
mainstream
and so as a technologist myself i got
really excited
about this idea of mashing up social
networking technology
location-based systems and then
mobile to create something that
connected real people
in the real world to get real things
done
and so literally my husband kevin and i
were talking
before the cab came to pick us up i
grabbed my iphone
and i went to godaddy.com and i said you
know what
such a site existed what would it be
called and i just immediately thought of
run myarin.com and it was available and
domain names are never available
so i took it as a sign i bought it on
the spot and
20 minutes later i hated the name by the
way so it's a whole other story we'll
get to
but it got us pretty far it got us
pretty far
so we rushed off to dinner we were
eating at this this restaurant in boston
um called masa wonderful southwest
tex-mex sort of restaurant
so literally over margaritas and
tortilla chips we're like okay
what's what does this product look like
what does this
site look like how do we leverage these
technologies to connect people
um and so you know at the time
i was an engineer at ibm i knew that i
could
build the product myself we weren't
thinking like
this is a company we weren't thinking
like let's go
launch a massive company that is going
to have global appeal we're like
this product should exist and i know i
can build it
so like how do we make that happen
so a few months later i walked into ibm
and i asked my manager if i could have
10 minutes of his time
and i quit my job and
it was really nerve-wracking i mean i
had been there seven years i loved
the people i worked with i really was
happy with what i was working on i felt
like i was still learning
not to mention i felt like i had this
massive career in front of me i mean
seven years
into ibm people stay there
for decades and really build their
careers there and
for me i think particularly as a female
engineer i felt like
ibm's like one of the top companies for
women to work for
like do i really want to throw all of
this away
um but i was so passionate about this
product
and about what i was building that i
decided to take the leap
um so kevin my husband and i we got
together and we thought we looked at our
finances
uh we owned a house in boston at the
time and we're like okay
if you quit your job today how
how much runway can we give ourselves to
actually make something happen
with this site with run my errand and uh
what i did is i cashed out my pension
from ibm
which was like i don't know twenty
thousand dollars that i had accrued over
the course of the last seven years and i
was like okay
what can we do with twenty thousand
dollars like how long will that take us
how
how much can we how much runway will
that give us
um and so we basically figured out that
we had about six months
this was june now it was four months
after i had the original idea
so by june i'd quit my job at ibm we had
said okay by the end of the year by
december
by christmas day we've gotta have
something happening
with this product otherwise you're gonna
have to go back you might have to go
back and grovel to your boss at ibm
and like ask him to take you back or
you're gonna have to go find another job
so what did i do i locked myself in this
room
for 10 weeks straight um this is the the
second bedroom in our house this is
where
really run my errand and where
taskrabbit was born you can see the
little doggie bed
under my desk there that's where kobe
would sleep um
but literally you know i had my computer
i had
my dog warming my feet and i had that
white board and a lot of post-it notes
and i basically um just started coding
now
at ibm i coded in c plus
a little bit of java at the end but that
was it i'd never done
web application development um and so i
started to research what sort of
languages would be
interesting to use at the time ruby on
rails was becoming really popular
literally did a uh on lamp tutorial one
weekend and was like
okay i got this i'm just gonna start
coding away and see what happens so
every morning i would get up i'd roll
out of bed
into this room and i would just get lost
in what i was building
and so for about 10 weeks straight
started developing
this concept this minimum viable product
this prototype i was calling it for
taskrabbit
um i took it out to
as many people as i could early on as
many customers as i could
i spent a lot of time at our local
coffee shop as well once i had this sort
of beta version prototype built it was
more like an alpha version actually
and i'd show it to people and i'd say
like hey would you use a service like
this what would use it for how much
would you pay
i talk to people that could be possible
taskrabbits and i said
you know are you looking to make money
money are you looking for work what
sorts of jobs would you want to do and i
was trying to understand if there was
really a marketplace here really a way
to match both sides of the marketplace
at the same uh at the same prices for
the same category so that was a big
question early on i was like i don't
know if people
one will want to use this but two that
will actually be able to match
interests and pricing and location all
at the same time that seems pretty
complex
so the first lesson learned really came
down to
being able to tell everyone i met about
the idea so
you know sometimes folks say oh i was
nervous to share my idea with people
because i was afraid they were gonna
steal it
here is some news for you all i am not
the first person to have this idea
this is a very simple idea right connect
with someone else in your neighborhood
around you that can help with a job
definitely not the
first person to have this idea and
people come up to me all the time and
they're like i had this
idea like 10 years gone like i bet you
did it's a great idea right um
and i'm like tell me about that like why
didn't you do it why didn't it work
it all really comes down to execution so
i'd say one
never worry about being afraid that
someone's gonna steal your idea there's
just so much
value in sharing your idea with as many
people as possible
getting feedback early on and then
developing it from there
as an example um i was out to dinner one
night here's another
restaurant we were eating at it's a
place in cambridge called ten tables
and we were out to dinner with my
husband one of his co-workers
um and a couple of other friends
and we're just chatting and i didn't
know them very well and i was like hey
i'd love to share this idea with you get
your feedback so i started talking about
it
and her name her name is a.g and a.g
says to me
you know who'd think this is really
interesting my buddy scott
and i was like oh yeah really she's like
yeah you should just email him
and just email him um and she gave me
his email address
and um you know just tell him about your
idea i think he could find it really
interesting now
i didn't ask too many questions i was
like okay cool another person i can get
feedback from
i didn't realize her buddy scott was
scott griffith the ceo of zipcar
so yeah uh ignorance is bliss sometimes
because i literally went home that night
it was like
midnight on a saturday and i was like
dear scott my name is leah buskie and i
have this idea
and your friend a.g says that you will
think it's really cool you know
i'm like if i could have 30 minutes of
your time i'd love to tell you about it
and to scott's credit he wrote me back
the next morning on a sunday morning
and i see his email signature i'm like
oh he's the ceo
of zipcar um
so he was very very nice and he said you
know what why don't you come into my
office tell me about what you're working
on you know i'd love to
i'd love to give you feedback and talk
about it
so i went over and let me see what the
next picture is okay this is
this is actually uh us at zipcar and
i'll get to this in a second
so scott and i met um i remember being
so nervous the night before our meeting
i didn't sleep at all
and i went into the zipcar office and i
sat down in his office
and he's like okay tell me about run my
errand at the time
so i told them about social location and
mobile and how
i thought all these technologies could
be mashed up to connect real people
in the real world in real time for real
things
and he was like cool like that's
actually a lot
what we're doing with zipcar you know we
have cars in these neighborhoods and
we're getting people to share
resources to live more efficiently
together and so he got the vision
immediately
and we just get got into this really
engaging conversation
about what the vision of run my errand
what
what taskrabbit could be what it could
grow into where zip car was going
and he just became an early mentor of
mine and so
i um i spent you know as much time as
scott would give me
uh with him at his office and we talked
about
you know our go-to-market plan and how
the product was coming along
um you know he he was the one that
started introducing me to other people
other mentors
investors angel investors i had no idea
about raising money um i didn't know
about angel
funding um i i started reading a lot of
books asking scott a lot of questions
and just tried to just try to get ahead
of the steep steep learning curve that
was ahead of me
um i literally didn't even know about
how
like equity worked in the company i was
like okay so
these investors they write you checks
but then like what if it doesn't work
out you have to give the money back
like what happens like i don't
understand and so
just to give you a sense of like where i
was coming from huge learning curve
there
um but i learned quickly and i had
amazing people like scott
being able to mentor and guide me along
the way so
when i quit ibm um scott offered me desk
space at the zipcar office how amazing
is that right
and this is our first employee brian
leonard who's our chief architect at
taskrabbit now
he and i worked together at ibm for five
years and so
actually the day i left ibm it's funny
we there's a group of us
a small group of us that were sort of of
the same same peer group and
they took me out to lunch in the last
day and brian was like what are you
doing
i told a mom working on this like new
product thing and he's like let me build
your mobile app for you and i was like
okay cool
and so that next summer he was like
coding away and because he just wanted
to play with ios and just come out
and so once once we got into the zip car
office brian came on board full time um
and i was able to hand over a lot of the
engineering
brains to him the first thing he did was
throw away all of my code
um literally you can ask him he was like
this is crap
starting from scratch and he did and
it's much better um
so i i was happy about that so
you know the first lesson of just
telling
anyone who'd listen to me about the idea
that's how i met scott i mean there's
there's no way it was so serendipitous
that i got connected to him and that we
really hit it off
you just never know where different
leads are going to take you and if you
can just be really open
about what you're working on open to
feedback open to connecting with people
just never know where that's going to
take you
so that was definitely the first big
lesson um
the second lesson is really around and
this builds off of my relationship with
scott just
creating a network around you of mentors
and collaborators of people that you can
rely on for guidance that you can ask
really
stupid questions to and they won't
they'll they'll be okay with that
um just people that you're comfortable
with
so i don't you guys might recognize
these two uh
john and logan who run a little company
called lyft
anyone um so they started out with a
company called zimride
um and this is us at facebook fund
in 2009. this was um
a 12-week sort of startup boot camp run
by dave mcclure which i think was a
speaker here as well so a lot of you
know dave
and run my iron and zim ride funny that
we both have different names now
um both participated in this summer
program
it's funny because at the time you know
i was still in boston i was working on
the zipcar office
and i had heard about this facebook fun
program
actually through scott and he was
telling me about it he knew about it
because he was doing a deal with zimride
zipcar and zimride were doing a deal
together
he actually introduced me to john and
logan john had flown out to the boston
area to wrap up this deal with zipcar
i met john at the zipcar office he and i
hit it off
and then all of a sudden they're telling
me like you've got to come out here to
facebook fund i'll talk to dave mcclure
i'll vouch for you
like this will be great and so again
like
another just serendipitous connection
there
so um facebook fun was a great
experience
because uh dave really ran it as a
startup bootcamp
and i remember day one who walked in
this is my first time on the west coast
at all
ever i mean i like stepped off the plane
into palo alto i'm like oh this is
heaven
i love it it smells like trees and
redwoods and it's so great here
um and walked into the
the fate the facebook fund office which
actually was facebook's first office
over in hamilton ave
and palo alto is a really cool space and
um dave is like okay great there's 20
companies here
you all are going to get up and you're
gonna give us your five minute
pitch and i'm like okay i got this like
scott had prepped me
coached me i've been pitching to a few
uh angel investors by that point
and so i was one of maybe
maybe the first to get up and go i
wasn't the first
but after every pitch dave
rated you on a scale of zero to ten
i know you can imagine where this is
going and so i got up and i gave my
pitch
and i had it memorized and it was full
of all this marketing lingo and i felt
really good about it and dave's like
that was a three he's like that sucked
he's like you've got a long way to go
and i'm like oh my god
i've got so much work to do here but
you know what the next week i gave the
pitch again and it was an eight
and so again i just learned very quickly
and i really appreciated
all of the the learnings that came out
of facebook fun the mentorship that came
out there
and the amazing people that i just got
to surround myself with
with and work with and it really
accelerated my growth as well as an
entrepreneur
and and accelerated run my errands
growth as a company and and we're
getting close to where it became
taskrabbit actually
um so one of the uh
interesting days at facebook fund was i
was flying back and forth between boston
and san francisco and i would spend one
week in boston one week in san francisco
at facebook fund back and forth back and
forth
and i had my weeks planned out and on a
friday night
i had just landed um from san francisco
back to boston
and i get an email from dave it's an
email to everyone in the group and he
says
hey just so you know tim ferriss will be
here
on monday and there's 15 minute slots
you can sign up to meet with him
uh tim is the author of the four hour
work week
he has a new york times bestseller he
writes a lot about how you can live
efficiently live productively
outsourcing i was like oh my god i need
to meet tim i knew who he was i read his
book
and i thought you know what if anyone
would be another great inve
uh advisor to add to taskrabbit it would
be tim but i just
landed back in boston from san francisco
on a friday night
and so i looked at flights and i was
like okay if i went back out on sunday
how much would it cost
this is last minute and the ticket was
like eight hundred dollars
and i'm still bootstrapping this startup
by myself right eight hundred dollars is
a lot of money
and i'm like what could i do with eight
hundred dollars i could i could like
fly your whole neighborhood and and
do like all kinds of scrappy mark
scrappy marketing things or i could run
some like facebook ads or or google ads
or something with 800
but i was like okay if i could turn this
into i don't know like a million dollars
then it'll be worth it that's literally
what went on in my head and i'm like
okay if i book this flight i'm gonna go
out there i'm gonna get tim as an
advisor
he's gonna help me close around to
funding and not like that is the only
way this is going down
and so i decided to book the flight
um on the way out there sunday night i
reread four hour work week just so i was
you know up to date and familiar with
everything
and met tim at facebook fun there on
monday
so we each had a 15-minute time slot and
i was like okay
my goal is to just get him to agree to a
next meeting because in 15 minutes i
can't really convince him that he would
be the perfect advisor to me and to
to run my errands and so i just need to
wow him enough for him to be like
okay we'll we'll we'll chat again and
i'll give you another meeting
so i walk in and i'm like tim will you
sign my book
i'm a huge fan really excited about how
you think about the space would love to
tell you about run my aaron
and helping people live more efficiently
live productively in a neighborhood
and he's like okay great and i'm showing
him like the home page and he's like you
should tweak this on the homepage i bet
conversions will increase and i'm like
okay awesome i'm taking notes and
writing things down
and i'm watching the clock and i'm like
okay it's getting to like a couple
minutes left i'm like so
tim is there any way you'd be willing to
spend more time with me
i would be so appreciative you know i
just feel like there's a lot of synergy
between what you're writing about
in my business i would love to get more
of your thoughts
and at this point he probably thinks i'm
a crazy woman because i'm like
i like roll in there i'm like sign my
book look at my website
like you would be a great advisor and he
hesitated and he's like okay he's like
you know email my assistant
um and you know we'll see if we can set
something up
so i'm like great so of course i leave
and the first thing i do is i email his
assistant i'm like hey amy i just met
with tim
um you know he said that he'd be willing
to spend more time with me
you know can i grab an hour with him you
know sometime next week
and she wrote back really fast and it
turns out tim was using this virtual
assistant uh platform of course he was
because he's super efficient and um
so so she said you know what he has some
availability next week for a phone call
and i'm like ah
phone call like i just met him in person
i feel like i feel like if i could get
him in person again like i could really
convey my passion around the business
and really tell him the story and get it
get his real feedback
and so i was going to be in boston that
week and i said you know what
i'm gonna be in the area anyway i'm
gonna be in the neighborhood like if
he's available
can what can we just set up lunch or
coffee or
so i kind of pushed her on it and i said
i was gonna be there and she was like
okay you know he he
agreed to do a lunch and so tim and i
met over
um at osha thai restaurant for lunch in
glen park and
by that point i had sort of my demo my
pitch deck sort of
outlined um and but i haven't really
started talking to investors out here
yet and so i wanted to get his feedback
on that
so over lunch we're kind of going
through the deck and you know he's
asking me a lot of really great
questions and we're having a great
conversation
and you know at the end i'm like okay so
you know i'd love it if you would
consider coming on
as an advisor i just feel like there's
so much value you can add i feel like
the work that we're doing has a lot of
synergy
and he was like all right let's do it
and i was like okay
this is step one to the million dollar
prize
um and so the first thing he did
was uh send out a couple emails
to a few uh friends of his that were
investors
and one of them was anne mariko you guys
may recognize her
she's a professor here um and anne and i
met
uh over breakfast one morning this is at
palo alto creamery we recreated the
moment for a photographer
in a magazine one time we had a lot of
fun um
but this was a recreation of our first
meeting and tim
had entered me to her tim also sent an
intro to steve anderson at baseline
ann and steve do a lot of work together
and
they ended up leading a million dollar
seed round
uh for run my earned at the time for
taskrabbit
at the end of facebook fund and so i was
like okay success
i have created this 800 ticket into
my seed financing felt really good about
that
but it was it was really risky i mean it
was it was really taking that leap of
faith
so ann and i met over breakfast really
hit it off
she got the business immediately got the
vision immediately
um and she
at the time i was still in boston and
sort of flying back and forth but
facebook fun
had wrapped up the last time i flew
back the last week of facebook fund i
said to my husband i said
all right i think we should sell the
house i think you need to quit your job
i think we i think we should move west i
think that's where things are happening
and we got to be there for it
and to his credit he was like all right
let's do it
and he did it um and so
ann led a million-dollar seed round for
us
we packed up and we drove across the
country
and we moved here and i wanted to be
closer to ann
and the seed round investors i also
wanted to get san francisco open
as our second market so at this point it
was still
run my errand it was still only in
boston i still hated the name
and i was like okay we got to get san
francisco open and like this is when
we're gonna switch over to
to a new name to a new brand
um so we packed up the car we threw kobe
the 100-pound yellow lab in the back
and drove seven days across the country
uh it was the trip of a lifetime we had
such a great time
so many great memories from that trip
and
uh we got here uh to the bay area
and we set up an office
um in soma and this is kobe at our first
office space uh here in san francisco
so how did we go from run my iron to
taskrabbit
um so basically
i knew that the name run my errands
would only take us so far and i felt
like
it was great because it really expressed
what the site was at the time like
i needed dog food i needed someone to
run my errand
and they did it and it all made sense
but i felt like
as we built out the product and we got
it launched in boston
we're starting to realize that like this
actually was a
big business this actually was a company
this was actually something that people
around the globe had started emailing us
emailing us about and were really
excited about and then i thought
you know this name run my errand it's
only going to take us so far
it's such a small sliver of the vision
for the company at this point and i also
felt like
it was a little demeaning like run my
air and just felt like a command and i
really didn't want it to feel that way i
wanted it feel like
this community this network this this
neighborhood
feel and so we came up with
hundreds and hundreds of names just like
so many names it was such a grueling
exercise
we had like naming parties at our house
and we like
brought our friends over and we had like
pizza and beer and we're like come up
with names
um really bad ones we came up with were
um
could you i don't even know how you
spell that
um taskrabbit was like in the mix there
was another one that was like
blue crew i don't know and at the time
it was like
sears was running those commercials with
like the blue crew and there was like
this service thing i don't know
um so there were some really bad ones
but there were also some really good
ones
we came up with this top five list and
taskrabbit was not my first choice
actually it i it didn't really resonate
with me i was like i was not sold on it
my first choice was red rover we'll send
someone right over it had like the dog
theme i fell in love with that name
but what we did to decide is
at that point we're live in boston for
about a year now like we had a pretty
good community of people utilizing the
service
and we asked them we said okay if you
could rename and rebate
re-brand the service like which name
would you vote on and we had the names
we had sort of placeholder logos so
people could visualize the way we were
thinking about the brand
like little taglines too and taskrabbit
just was like a runaway
success in that poll like everybody
loved the name taskrabbit
um that and i could not get the domain
name for red rover this woman in new
york owns it she makes dogs
dog collars and she like would not sell
it to me um
so i was like okay everybody loves
taskrabbit anyway so i'm just gonna
focus on that
we literally i think we like spent seven
hundred dollars on it
um and bought the domain rebranded the
whole
site um so this was remember i told you
brian threw away all my code
he started from scratch and he started
building up what would then become
taskrabbit and we got that site launched
in san francisco
at the same time we switched the brand
in boston so now we're live in two
cities under
this new name new product and this
ended up being by like the summer of
2010.
so the timeline here is left ibm june
um almost decided to close up
shop by the end of that year because we
hadn't raised money yet
but decided to do facebook fund
incubator program in the summer of 09
that took us to the end of raising the
seed round with anne
and then by the following summer we got
out here to the bay area finally
and got san francisco launched as our
second market
so the importance of just surrounding
yourself
with amazing advisors mentors people
that can
help you along the way people that can
be a sounding board
um for me was
what made or break made or broke the
company in the early days having scott
involved having tim
involved um funny story about
michael eisner getting involved he saw
um a segment that we
ran on diane sawyer's world news tonight
and that team had approached us and were
like
we we heard you're doing really
interesting things with taskrabbits and
you're fixing the unemployment problem
and so they ran this whole segment on us
michael eisner saw it his team called us
and was like we want to help what can we
do and i was like michael eister
like i remember anyone remember the
disney sunday night movie
i don't know i just i don't know okay
maybe it's a different age group but
um i i remember watching michael eisner
on sunday nights and he was like friends
with mickey mouse like this guy was my
hero
um and so we got him involved um
in 2011 and he and his team have been
an awesome help for us down in the la
area as well
so i wanted to talk a little bit about
one of
out of all the things i've had to learn
from
raising money to marketing to
product design engineering teaching
myself ruby on rails
i've got to say the hardest one for me
and i think one of the most important
ones is like just building the right
team
just finding great people that you want
to work with
that are smarter than you that can take
the concept to a whole other level
um and it for me i feel like
those early days were a real struggle
particularly because we didn't have any
money to pay people so you really had to
convince them that this was something to
join because they were just as
passionate about the idea as you were
over time we've been able to build such
an incredible team
but some of those key team members and
uh
this is our ceo stacy right here
took a really long time um
to actually meet and get involved in the
company so tell you a little bit about
stacy
she um she worked at google uh for 12
years
and we were running a co search and i
had met
stacey what a year 18 months
before she came on board to taskrabbit
and i met her like
five weeks after she had had her first
baby
and at the time i was just meeting
awesome people
trying to build out the team she had
just had her sweet baby emma and was
like this is not a good time for me but
like i really like what you're doing
let's stay in touch
we stayed in touch for a year and a half
finally the timing was right
she came on board to taskrabbit as her
ceo and that partnership between stacy
and i has just been
awesome she i wanted to find someone
that was just as passionate about
the business pieces the scale pieces the
operational pieces
as i am about engineering and product
and design
and so the the partnership that we've
built has been such a great balance
um but again you just never know where
those relationships where those
connections are gonna take you
and it literally was a year and a half
before the timing was right to get
stacey on board and to have her come
work with us at taskrabbit but it's been
an amazing partnership
so the last lesson learned is
and this may seem obvious but i think
for me because i started from a place
where it was just like
i wasn't looking to build a company i
just was really passionate about this
product i wanted to get it out of the
market i felt like there's a lot of
people that could use it and
it could be helpful you have to be so
passionate about what you're doing and
love what you do every day
because there's so many ups and downs
and crazy things you have to learn and
do
and you know people think startups are
so glamorous
and it's just like oh my god it is not
glamorous at all
it is just grueling but if you love what
you do
if you're passionate about what you do
it makes it all worth it
for me i knew that we were on to
something
massive when i heard this story from our
community and this happened pretty early
on
there's a mom we're only launched in two
cities and there's a mom here in san
francisco
and she has a 20 year old son
living in boston and those are the only
two cities we were launched in
at the time and unfortunately her son 20
years old
was going through chemotherapy treatment
at mass general hospital
and she is a librarian here um
she didn't have the money the budget to
fly out there to be with him
throughout his treatment so she went on
to task rabbit
she found someone that could go visit
her son
every day in the hospital for a week
bring him a healthy meal
a cozy blanket sit with him for 30
minutes every single day and then call
her afterwards and just give her the
update like how is he really doing
the person that picked up the job in
boston was actually another mom
and the mom that these two the bond that
these two moms formed
across the country was incredible and i
realized that
what we had built wasn't just about
getting dog food it wasn't just about
running errands we were actually
redefining who your neighbors are who
you can rely on
and so when stories like that come
through
you love what you do you realize the
impact that you're having
and it doesn't matter the tough day that
you've had
or you know that that next round of
funding that you're not sure you're
gonna get it's like this is
this is why you do it this is what makes
it all worth it
another quick story that's one of my
favorites and because i'm clearly a dog
person i have to end on the dog note
um there is a uh
scene a visually impaired person uh
living in boston
and she needed someone to walk her
service dog for her
just like get her some extra exercise
and so there's a task rabbit that goes
every day and walks the service dog for
her for
an hour gets them out gets some fresh
air
and brings them back to her every single
day
and so it's again stories like this that
you just realize
the platform that you've built the
company that you've stumbled on and
discovered and created
um is actually impacting people around
the globe in a way
that um you only hoped was possible and
it is
so the thing that i'll leave you with
and then i'm happy to just
dive into any areas or answer any
questions is
you know i think that because i wasn't
looking to start a company i felt like
this idea i had for taskrabbit that so
many other people had before me again i
wasn't the first one to have this idea
it really was a discovery it really was
a creative process of
of asking the right questions of
understanding
where the pain points are for the user
how we can make these connections
through technology to connect real
people in the real world in real time
and so it's really about
um having this idea and discovering
that it can actually be something bigger
that has so much impact on a global
scale
so i'll leave you with that happy to
answer any questions you have
a question yes
right there in the back red shirt thank
you so much
great presentation question for you is
how did you build your user base
when you started early on how did you
slowly build your user base what were
the challenges
and how do you scale up it's a great
question so the question was
early on how did i build the user base
what were the challenges how did i scale
up
great question because when i first
launched the service in boston
i launched it in one neighborhood and it
was the neighborhood i was living in at
the time
charlestown not only did i only launch
it in one neighborhood
in that neighborhood i went to the
charlestown mothers organization
which were 600 moms in one square mile
and i thought moms are really busy
now i know because i'm a mom myself but
then i didn't just figured they were
busy
um and i said i've got these 600 moms if
i could find like
30 taskrabbits to fulfill the needs of
these moms on this site like
that will be a good start so i started
there and did a closed beta with that
mom's group
and then it just really started to
amplify from there so started to open it
up
mom started telling other moms in
cambridge and brookline
and beacon hill and back bay and i
started having to recruit task rabbits
in those areas too
and so i would say you know one of the
big challenges
we even see today um is
you have to go for us it was helpful to
go really narrow with our focus
in the early days it was this mom's
group now
we even still see actually a big
working mother's demographic that we
market to that we build product around
that we build messaging around
as well and i would say making sure that
you're tracking those customer
demographics customer analytics all the
way through will
really help you decide where to focus
yes yes to the taskrabbit in the front
row
so what are your plans to go global and
then what barriers are you facing right
now
and going in different countries
speaking different languages good
question so the question is um
when do we think about going global and
what barriers are we facing so
we just opened london as our second
market late last year
um and we did that because
we felt like it would be sort of a great
jumping off point
to the rest of europe it's also english
speaking
although actually the language and
localization is very very different
um any american company that thinks they
can launch
in london with us english it's crazy and
they get very offended
and so we actually built out this whole
localization platform
and for english speaking uk
and launched there so now that we have
the localization the infrastructure and
architecture built into the product
it would be fairly easy for us to go as
far as like translating to other
languages to other places
i think the key thing that we're going
to have to deal with challenge-wise is
that every country has different labor
laws
so for example in france uh the labor
laws there are completely different
they're really stringent um you know you
actually can't terminate an employee
like ever it's really hard to do that
um people it i'm not even kidding
um people when they leave jobs have to
give
like nine months notice it's it's so
different so culturally i think there
will be some differences and labor laws
we'll have to think about for now
um we can do a lot of cities in europe
pretty easily we also have big waiting
lists
in sydney australia and then in canada
would be easy for us to do toronto and
vancouver so we'll probably be looking
at those sometime in 2015 i think
yeah yes kind of metrics or traction did
you have when you did your
a million dollar wrap good question so
the question was what sort of metrics or
traction did i have when we did our
first
seed round um so i'll say a couple
things about that one it was a very
different time than it is now
so i you know quit my job at ibm
june of 2008 launched the site in
september
of 2008 the stock market was crashing
people were getting laid off left and
right i was like oh my god what did i
just do
leaving this cushy job at ibm started
trying to raise money and it was really
really hard people were not writing
checks at that time
did facebook fund and so by that point
i was launched in a bunch of
neighborhoods
in the boston area we were looking at
metrics
like match rate close rate
the unit economics per task so
on average we take a 20 percent cut
of every transaction that flows through
the site so we're making sure that those
unit economics worked
the numbers were still very small at the
time
and we knew that we needed to get to
more cities
to learn faster too about what sort of
product needed to be built
so i would say early on it was really
focusing on what are the key metrics not
necessarily like how good do they look
but then what's the path forward and how
fast can we prove those things
straight in the back there um i was
wondering
this morning in the new york times there
was an article about instacart
and it had two main points one was that
instacart is a you know another one it's
an online grocery
shopping um it's similar to taskrabbit
but it is
best like specializing in grocery
shopping and i'm wondering like
a to what degree to what extent do you
think that the market has all these
different little niches where you can
have ride sharing you can have
you can be sending out people to do your
grocery shopping there can be a separate
company for sending out people to like
do your laundry or do you see taskrabbit
as
if you think we're gonna out compete
these guys we are the umbrella
company for this and then my the other
point that the article had was that
it's that these companies are
are offering a solution like you said to
the unemployment problem they're
creating a new um section a new class of
jobs essentially and i'm wondering like
again you know to whatever degree do you
believe that that's
really true and will actually end up
becoming a full employment pool yeah
so great question so the first question
was about
well they both came from this new york
times article and um the first question
was basically if i
if i uh just kind of boil it down
it's really about a horizontal play
versus a vertical play
would you agree with that um so this is
something that
we debate all the time and there are
these vertical players that have popped
up
in grocery delivery and house cleaning
and certain verticals in certain spaces
and it's kind of like
are you going to have an app on your
phone for 10 different things
or are you going to create the brand and
the platform
that people go to whenever they need
anything done
um our approach has always been this
horizontal play i think what we've
learned is that
we're really good at things around the
home
and that these home services categories
are definitely something that
the majority of people are posting so
it's high volume for us already
that our taskrabbits really enjoy doing
so we have the supply side of the
marketplace sort of locked down in those
categories as well
so i think that you'll see us start to
focus in and around the home
but i believe that the opportunity
and the power is in building a
horizontal platform that can service a
lot of different types of categories i
mean i can see us
down the road in the future sort of
moving up the chain even into more
professional services skill-based
services um to me that's the interesting
piece
and i think it's because you know i
started with sort of a product mindset
of i wanted to solve this pain point and
this problem
i didn't want to create a dog food
delivery company you know
and so for me the opportunity is in
having the impact
um that we see that we're having you
know with the two moms with
the the service dog um and so that's
that's the company that we're building
and that we're excited about
um second question was around
input yes so that is a very real thing
so the question is like are we really
um helping the unemployment
um uh percentages and and
the truth is yes we are so we have right
now
30 000 task rabbits across the country
that
are active i mean how many companies let
alone startups can say
like they've found work for 30 000
people in the last five years like
that's huge
out of that group 10 of them are doing
this full-time
they're making all of their income from
taskrabbit they're cashing out
something like five thousand dollars a
month they're doing two to three jobs a
day
um 75 of the community
relies on taskrabbit in some way to make
their monthly
income um so it is a very
real problem that we're solving um
one of the little tidbits i'll say too
is
early on in boston i thought boston is a
great college town we're going to get
all these college students that want to
become task rabbits that want to make
money
but that actually was my first big
learning because that was never the case
we had such a wide variety of people
that wanted to become taskrabbits that
wanted to become involved in the
community
i think honestly part of it was timing i
launched in september of 2008
i was getting teachers that had just
been laid off lawyers that had just been
laid off pharmacists
all these folks were looking for work to
take them
in between jobs in between careers um
but even as the job market has improved
our interest in
becoming a taskrabbit in the supply side
has only improved as well um so
i also think there's this notion of
empowering people to build out their own
businesses on the platform to be their
own bosses this idea of micro
entrepreneurship these task rabbits get
to set their own prices say
who they want to work for say what jobs
they're good at they really have control
of their own destiny and i think
that flexibility is something that they
really appreciate about the service as
well so
i'm excited to continue to see what we
can do to help
unemployment in this country and many
others around the globe as well
in the gray shirt
yes um in another course that i'm in
the one of the professor's favorite
services to um
to kind of put down is amazon's
mechanical troop because of
how low the the price point from
many tasks are um does taskrabbit have
an infrastructure
in place to ensure that the the um
the payments agreed upon are reasonable
yeah great question it's something we
think a lot about so the question was
in the example of amazon mechanical turk
the prices are so low
what sort of infrastructure has
taskrabbit built to ensure
what i would call fairness in the
marketplace
and that people have agreed on pricing
so
one of the interesting things about the
model
is that we don't claim to be
the cheapest service like in many
categories we are not the cheapest
service
our taskrabbits set their hourly rates
per category they say what they're good
at they say what their time is worth
and on the other side the clients who
book
jobs who need to find help they can look
through these profiles they can look
through ratings and reviews they can see
how experienced
taskrabbit is in a certain category and
decide if they want to work with them or
not
so we ensure that people
are setting fair prices
one thing we don't allow people to um
book task rabbits below
minimum wage just flat out it's not
going to happen on the service
um and you know we encourage taskrabbits
to set the prices that they're
comfortable
with i think you see a lot of
other companies right now particularly
in the peer-to-peer space and the
sharing economy
that it's almost becoming a race to the
bottom
because they're so competitive in nature
and i think you know
frankly this is happening in
transportation we see this with the
competitors in the space they're all
undercutting each other
undercutting undercutting and uh what's
important to us at taskrabbit
is that we empower people to build out
their businesses on the platform that
they feel
good about finding work um on the
taskrabbit community
and that they feel like they're getting
paid a fair wage it's super important
yes in the middle there nice
presentation leah
i wanted to know whether or not you have
a marketing budget and
what your like top three methods are for
both acquiring your customers
as well as finding those task rabbits
great question so the question was what
type of marketing budget do we have
what have been like the top three things
that have worked for um what we call
clients and taskers
so we've tried a lot of things um you
know early on in the early days
there clearly was no marketing budget
except for my credit card
and um i literally would like fly your
neighborhoods and just do
really scrappy like gorilla style
tactics to get the word out
you know as we've matured as a company
as we've raised 40 million dollars today
we certainly have
a budget now dedicated to marketing
and we'll say that to this day 75
of our clients of our users come in via
word of mouth
in pr they're unpaid we are still
testing paid channels um
you know people are searching for things
like house cleaners in san francisco and
so some of those
uh paid uh keywords uh in sem
have worked well for us the other
interesting thing recently that we just
tried that worked well
was the first time we did this what's
called out of home
and we have these bus ads running in san
francisco on the muni i don't know if
any has anyone seen them
you guys are probably mostly down here
but if you go to san francisco
look at the muni uh buses going around
there they're kind of everywhere right
now
we ran three different ads um one of
them was highly targeted
to this mom demographic and the campaign
was mommies need nap time too
um you know find a task rabbit to help
you with yourself
another one was moving sucks
the life out of you and so is really
targeted to a specific category that we
see that's really active on the site
um and so those out of home
bus ads actually drove a lot of traffic
and we were able to track it because we
set up separate landing pages for them
and then we attract users coming in
through that landing page so the cpa on
those the cost per acquisition
was a lot lower actually than we saw for
sem and online so that is an interesting
tidbit
i'll say that on the tasker side on the
supply side
that is the easy side of the marketplace
there's no shortage of people that want
to earn money that want to become
taskrabbits in fact we have
huge waiting lists of people um
all over the country even all over the
world that we
sort of have to add into the community
as demand spikes and increases
in certain zip codes in certain
categories so there's a lot of analytics
there
green crime prevention
someone get into the house what was the
question
prevention criteria okay great question
so what do we do for crime prevention so
from the very beginning even when it was
just me in that second bedroom of my
house
one of the first things i did was think
about this and the peer-to-peer economy
hadn't even started yet and but i knew
that trust and safety
and a really strong vetting platform was
going to be super important
and so even back in those days a hundred
percent of the task rabbits that were
part of the community
went through background check we did
that from day one
um and i mean i remember just
researching all the different background
checking companies understanding like
how i could build this
into the product in an automated way
with some apis to make it really
efficient and scalable
and so you know today we have
a whole vetting program and includes a
series of background checks
it verifies your identity identity it
looks at criminal background as well
we also put all of our task rabbits
through a training program
program we're testing an in-person
training program now as well in san
francisco that's been going really well
um from there they build up their
reputation in the community and so
there's this whole reputation engine as
well
that's really important to the trust and
safety on the site so
you can see how many jobs the taskrabbit
has done you can see their ratings and
reviews
they can actually level up on the site
and earn different levels of activity
rosemary is one of our top elite
taskrabbits
in the country she's here in san
francisco she does
a bajillion house cleaning tasks and is
like a level 33 taskrabbit um that is
the highest i've seen on the site
you start out at level one and it's this
like logarithmic equation of like
level 33 so she's pretty awesome um so
yes since day one that's been
super important i think any of these
peer-to-peer
marketplace companies it's just
something that's table stakes now that
you have to get right
and you have to be thinking about thank
you